- Literal bells.
- There we go.
(bells jingling)
Christmas (bleep).
(holiday music)
- [Selorm] Christmas music, in my opinion,
is one of the most interesting genres.
Chances are, you're listening
to Christmas classics
that were made decades ago.
In fact, the two most
modern songs that you'll
probably find on Billboard's
top Christmas list
are "All I Want For Christmas Is You"
by Mariah Carey, and
"Last Christmas" by Wham!
Many artists don't even bother to write
original Christmas songs
knowing they can make a killing
singing the same classics
that everyone already knows.
So I thought, what's the harm in trying
and while fiddling around with my ukulele,
I came up with this:
I had a feeling that I was on to something
so I asked my college friend Irene
to co-write the song with me.
- My name is Irene.
Despite my musical
background, I don't feel
all too confident in writing music.
I'm more of a singer and piano player.
- I love songwriting but
I feel like I've never
tried to challenge myself.
But it would be really cool
to try something different
like a Christmas song.
- [Selorm Voiceover] Even
though Irene and I had
a lot of musical talent,
we needed some help
when it came to writing the song.
So we sought out advice from
hit singer and songwriter Scotty Grand.
- Christmas songs are really about
painting pictures with their lyrics.
When it comes to finding a great concept,
go with things that are universal:
love, getting your heart broken,
but you still have to stand out.
What haven't you heard them talk about?
Go there and then bring it
home with something human.
- Even though I like a
lot of Christmas songs,
I don't always relate to them.
- I've never had a
white Christmas, either.
So any song that involves snowing,
I can't relate to it, sorry.
- That's so sad, Irene.
- Well, I'm from Guam, it's hot there.
- Let's definitely go with that theme.
Like just an unconventional Christmas.
- Songs should be simple.
It could be repetitive, just
like Mariah Carey's song.
She uses repetition.
- For the chorus that I
have so far, it's like
♪ Doesn't matter where you are ♪
♪ When it plays you're
right where you belong ♪
♪ This whole world is a gift we're given ♪
♪ So put a little Christmas in it ♪
♪ Ooh, put a little Christmas in it ♪
- Hit Christmas songs,
they use seventh chords.
They use diminished chords.
One, three, five, that's a regular chord.
Now if you go two steps down,
that's the seventh chord.
And these chords kind of play
off the jazz era of music.
Where the lyrics were
telling more of a story.
- Dude.
I did it, I made words (laughing)
- You made words.
♪ Tryna find that Christmas cheer ♪
- Yeah, Christmas mood was the word.
- I did something bad.
I got so excited about me and Irene
making some progress on the song
that I actually sent an email out
to our entire office
saying that we'd perform it
and the only day that we could
do that is three days away.
I'm a little worried because more than
half of the song isn't done yet.
Right now, I'm actually talking to a
friend of mine, RJ Tolson.
He's a great music maker, he's going to
make us a track that we can perform live.
So I woke Irene up.
So I wrote something for the chorus.
What do you think?
We're doing it, bitch.
We're doing it.
- I need to go back to sleep.
- Okay, I love you.
Bye.
We are stuck up here in this little loft.
We've got some of the lyrics down so far.
We just have to write the second verse
and we're pretty much good.
Right, Irene?
- And then practice it a million times.
- So this is how many lines we're probably
going to need for it.
♪ So you something something something ♪
(marker squeaking)
So basically--
- [Irene] That's a lot of lines.
- [Selorm] This is how
many spots we need to fill
before we get to the chorus.
- First two needs to be more about
the things you do to get
in the Christmas spirit.
- So I wrote, it won't
matter where you are,
whether home is near or far.
♪ ether home is near or far ♪
♪ All it takes is just a memory ♪
♪ Of a time when you were ♪
- We just need two more lines.
- No, we need to stop
using the word "feel".
- We don't use it that much.
- Yeah, we do.
♪ Time when you were young ♪
♪ And you hold your-- ♪
♪ And you hold it close and don't let go ♪
- What are you going to do
to get yourself back to this
place when you were young?
You're going to play your
motherfucking favorite
Christmas song.
But I don't know how to get there.
- Yeah.
♪ Your favorite Christmas song ♪
- That's perfect.
Fuck yeah.
- Yes.
We got it, we got it.
You think we're going to do okay?
- We'll see.
The next main thing is
just not being nervous
and performing it with confidence.
- I'm going to be sad if they don't
like the song or if they don't feel it.
Who gives a shit what
they think? (laughing)
We made a great song, so whatever, right?
(audience cheering)
(applause)
- That was incredible.
- I identified with the song greatly
because none of my family lives
in California, they all
live in the midwest.
- Okay, I thought this was
like a Jason Mraz song.
- Even if you don't celebrate Christmas,
you kind of celebrate
the season and the vibe.
I like that tagline of
"put some Christmas in it",
so put some Christmas in it.
- This was about making new traditions
and new memories and I think the song
showcases that a lot.
- When is it coming out on iTunes
because I'll buy it legally (laughs).
- When we started writing this
I didn't really know if we could do it.
But then to actually perform it
in front of people was mindblowing.
- This was an original song that
no one had ever heard her before.
When you're writing an original,
it's putting puzzle pieces
together, but you don't know
what the puzzle is supposed to look like.
I think because we really
believed in what we were writing,
we were able to make
something really special.
This really shows you that whatever
artistically you feel
like, you want to express
Or do, you can do it.
You could write the next "All
I What For Christmas is You."
It's still a challenge,
but you'll be surprised
at what you're actually capable of doing
once you set your mind to something.
- (speaking together) Merry Christmas.
(laughing)
- That was in tune, we were both in unison
- It was a harmony.
♪ Put a little Christmas in it. ♪